victimes. Pour le moment,
on rapporte au moins un mort :
une femme, dont le corps a été
retrouvé par les secouristes.
Carla Oliveira.
- Dévastation;
c'est le constat fait
à Casamicciola Terme après
des pluies torrentielles qui ont
provoqué un glissement
de terrain. Nous sommes sur
l'île volcanique d'Ischia, à
une trentaine de kilomètres de
Naples.
La boue a tout entraîné
avec elle : maisons et voitures.
Rien n'a été épargné
sur son passage. Certains
véhicules ont fini leur parcours
partiellement ensevelis sur
la plage ou carrément
dans la mer.
Le nettoyage des rues a
commencé et les secouristes ont
signalé avoir débuté les
recherches pour retrouver
des gens portés disparus.
Plus tôt dans la journée,
la confusion régnait sur le
nombre de disparus; le ministre
italien de l'Infrastructure
ayant annoncé huit morts
Il a été démenti par
son collègue de l'Intérieur qui
a expliqué que les conditions
météorologiques ont rendu
difficile le début
des opérations detetetetage.
Des opérations qui
se poursuivent, entre autres,
pour aller secourir des familles
prisonnières de leur maison,
dont les accès sont bloqués
par la boue.
Les autorités locales demandent
d'ailleurs aux habitants
de l'île de rester à la maison
afin de ne par gêner
les opérations de secours.
La ville de Casamicciola Terme
compte 8 000 habitants en hiver.
Connue pour ses thermes,
la ville a été frappée
par un séisme en 2017.
De nombreux immeubles s'étaient
alors effondrés et les experts
avaient, à l'époque, dénoncé
les constructions illégales
et de piètre qualité qui mettent
en danger les résidents
lors des désastres naturels.
Ici Carla Oliveira,
Radio-Canada, Montréa